merci la parole est maintenant madame
Béatrice Gosselin pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
outre-mer en 2022 le nombre de titres de
séjour autorisant à résider et à
travailler en France a augmenté de plus
de 17% par rapport à 2021 ainsi plus de
320 000 titres ont été délivrés contre
un peu plus de 277 000 en 2019 qui sont
les qui est la dernière référence
significative avant la pandémie jamais
la France n'attribué autant de titres de
séjour et accueilli autant de demandeurs
d'asile alors qu'elle peine toujours à
expulser les illégaux qui vivent sur son
territoire
cette situation difficilement tenable
témoigne de l'incroyable pression
migratoire qui pèse sur notre pays car
comme vous le savez on dénombre près de
700 000 clandestins sur le sol national
ces chiffres sont en total décalage avec
le discours offensif de votre
gouvernement sur la question des
expulsions de clandestins certes si vous
privilégiez la qualité sur la quantité
en reconduisant priorités et les
terroristes étrangers sortant de prison
il n'en reste pas moins que les
procédures d'éloignement recensées par
vos services sont au nombre de diles
9425 pour 2022 et ce chiffre reste en
deçà de celui d'avant la crise sanitaire
en effet Monsieur Castaner a ordonné
presque 24000 retondus reconductions à
la frontière en 2019 résultat un quart
d'expulsion en moins par rapport à 2019
et cela correspond à moins de 3% du
nombre de personnes se trouvant en
situation irrégulière sur le sol
français
la maîtrise des flux migratoires doit
imposée de reconduire effectivement les
immigrés illégaux pour accueillir les
ayants droits dans les meilleures
conditions cela suppose des intentions
fermes et des actes clairs alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple qu'attendez-vous pour mettre fin
à cette situation à soutenable pour
notre pays
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice on peut être d'accord sur un
certain nombre de constats peut-être pas
surtout notamment le fait que la
comparaison avec 2019 peut paraît un peu
biaisée dans la mesure où deux grands
États qui aujourd'hui sont des états de
demande d'asile vous avez raison de dire
que cette maladie explose d'ailleurs
partout en Europe plus de 60%
2022 seulement je mets des guillemets
évidemment plus de 30% en France à
l'époque en 2019 l'Afghanistan et le
Mali nous avions des relations
convenables et beaucoup vous savez la
première demande d'asile en France et en
Europe c'est l'Afghanistan ce sont les
Afghans qu'on ne peut pas évidemment
reconduire et je ne parle pas à des
Iraniens si je connecte nos discussions
on met parfois reproché d'avoir fait un
certain nombre de reconnaissance avec la
Syrie avec l'Iran par exemple cependant
vous avez parfaitement raison les titres
de séjour augmentent nous pensons que la
politique gouvernement et la bonne
puisque pour la première fois ces titres
augmentent pour le travail et stagne
pour la famille le problème de la France
c'est un groupement familial trop
important un petit de travail trop peu
importante contrairement à l'Allemagne
par exemple et puis évidemment vous avez
raison aussi sur les éloignements et
même si je vous remercie d'avoir
remarqué qu'on double le nombre de
personnes qui sont soit radicalisées
soit criminels ou délinquants dans les
expulsions plus de 3000 étrangers
expulsés la dernière contre 1500 en 2019
vous avez raison c'est 15%
d'augmentation ne sont pas suffisants et
qu'est-ce que nous attendons nous
attendons de discuter avec les
assemblées du projet de loi que j'ai
justement eu l'honneur de présenter au
Conseil des ministres ce matin il faut
libérer le droit on met parfois deux ans
à 2 ans et demi par une décision de
justice définitive quand on est mise à
l'intérieur pour pouvoir expulser et
entre temps les personnes ont peut-être
fait un enfant sur le territoire de la
République ils ont peut-être travaillé
illégalement sur le territoire de la
République ils ont peut-être pu proposer
d'autres demandes de titres de séjour il
faut absolument mettre fin à ses
détournements de procédures il faut
évidemment pouvoir expulser des
personnes en relevant les protections
juridiques la fin de la fin de la double
peine c'est ce que nous proposons et il
faut évidemment avoir un discours
extrêmement clair
en vertu d'intégration les valeurs de la
République et la langue mais aussi
vis-à-vis des États qui sont des états
d'immigrations et donc oui madame la
sénatrice nous partageons le constat et
nous pensons que pour les Français il
faut un texte fort qui permet de
l'intérieur de pouvoir expulser plus
rapidement ces personnes
merci Madame Gosselin poignée de seconde
oui monsieur le ministre merci de votre
réponse
je présente préparation mais il est vrai
que les français s'inquiètent de cette
montée en puissance des émigrés et je
crois que une politique de situation
claire et ferme permettra d'accueillir
mieux les gens qui peuvent venir sur ce
territoire français merci